I'm sorry guys but I have to start off
with some shout outs and I do some shout
outs dawg
oh I want to do shout out to weapons of
chaos
aka will the bank of what's up what's up
will the banker these are all people
that play destiny with him they all want
shoutouts no destiny shoutouts
I have shoutout to sensei will sir was
uh q is that the eleven-year-old yes we
got hi fix who we do all he what what I
had what I've done now guys is I've
given people this guy high fixed money
to play on my behalf so I gave him my
gamertag and you're logging in for me my
login information and now he's just
playing on my behalf and George thought
that was weird why did you think that
was weird cuz you're supposed to play
video games for fun yeah and you're
paying other people to have fun for you
no no are you gonna enjoy all your new
embellishments on your or your shaders
if someone else got it for you and you
didn't get it yourself is it as
rewarding well I'm not gonna be able to
do it on my own I don't have the skills
I think you do I swear to God I don't I
swore I'd there's no way you said you
got close once you playing right no I
went to the I went to the wood
lighthouse with high fix and tomorrow
lamp tomorrow then what's up
Tomorrowland yes but it was a fluke
because we tried it again and I'm just
bringing the team down so I gave him my
information he went to the lighthouse hi
figs with my character but you know
what's [ __ ] up also he changes my
controls your settings and the settings
so when I went went back to play again I
didn't know what button did what it was
like Oh lay out yeah lay at the layout
of it but I think I'm done with that I'm
done with the I'm done what that's me I
can't play anymore I don't have fun it's
not good when I walked in though he
looked Santa was like I play told me
George you played today and he did not
have fun well no I was playing the iron
banner with the team you know what's up
Danny Garcia did he go see you what's up
what's up know what
yeah and uh Sienna Garcia but he is such
a nice kid this guy he's Mexican and
he's from Chicago area and he's really
trying to help me he trusts include me
he texes me like hey you want to do the
raid and he's this nice guy and I want
to I really like you Danny but I think
I'm done
Danny I can't play anymore and fat black
is in Australia so I can't play with him
my brothers in Phoenix you know me and
Frank the doorman is driving me [ __ ]
crazy what do you mean
this [ __ ] right here so there's
a doorman named Frank Castillo last name
yeah I want his face his face I want to
squish his eyes into his [ __ ] sockets
Jesus no your eyes and your ass rock is
my [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] Bobby
anyway I'm gonna steal those guys from
me he would message them last night to
his own fire team no hi fixes do you
know got him Frank Castillo yeah look
he's been going behind my back and
messaging my guys right trying to go hey
I'm better than him just play with me
and he's trying to steal so he's dead
with me so when I go to the comedy store
tonight I'm not gonna even like that is
that not allowed in the gaming world -
he didn't told her not you these friends
of mine that I [ __ ] got our fans of
mind they're not frat fans of his you
know candy Garcia listens to targer
belly
you're a min hi fix his friend cool kid
19 kid 91 I got really urban here yeah
but yeah he's been trying to steal
people but uh and also I played with
this kid sensei he's 11 years old and I
there's a sense of number one I can't if
I'm he lives in Minnesota I can't have
lunch with him no you can no he's 11 as
his parents are abandoned
yeah but can I do that hey hey I'm
playing a club in Minnesota let me talk
to your dad
no just listen and then the dad got
what's up dude
you know I've been playing with sensei
for the last year I know he's 11 but you
guys won't have lunch with the parents
yeah with the parent yeah I'm not gonna
do it by myself I'll be where think
Chris Hansen will show up and all of a
sudden you know yeah yeah so some say
this little kid has a twin oh this kid
he does
you don't what are you doing that's
pretty much it you don't know what
you're doing
Bobby he doesn't know who you are at all
no I can't I don't have with Danny I can
have a little weight because I can go
you know I was in the movie The Dictator
or whatever I can I can try to you know
mean don't talk to me that way because
you know you know you know yeah um
people some people know who I am your
credits but some of these kids don't
give a [ __ ] so these kids these 11 year
olds 12 year olds I play where mute you
they just they mute me or they'll just
like talk to me in a way that um how
does that make you feel it makes me feel
sad but just I can't go I can't say hey
go to my IMDB they don't give a [ __ ] my
parents block that website I'm 11 you
know so um yeah I think it was done with
the game and I'm gonna play maybe um
Dead Rising the new one or that final
fantasy who knows but I'm done with
destiny for right now but I'm still
gonna let this kid - play for me every
weekend so you just like people you like
your character slot me all the armor
though it's not just armor what it does
is that if you get to the 9 lighthouse
you can get these things called on
ornaments and what they do is they make
they there's a hologram that happens on
to one of your armor pieces it looks
really cool yeah like what weather like
if you're Titan it gives you like you
know the wings or whatever and when
you're at the tower or the wreath these
are social spacious spaces when other
people are walking around I just like
chilling like I like sit down I like
chilling with my new gear so when you
get everything that you absolutely want
you're going to ask the fat black hole
Steve Frank and everybody be like hey
let's play is that black hope it's Eric
Griffin oh that was a lil I call him
is that what I call fat black hope it's
called fat black no I don't know okay
I'm gonna call that so what so you're
just gonna just so they can see all the
new stuff you have yeah they don't
really say much but I know what they're
feeling like damn he's good no I believe
that you did it all yourself I don't
care
don't tell them though I don't care it
didn't no that's not cheating it's how
was it cheating transaction I mean if I
had somebody elemental transit it's like
me going to a science exam and having my
sister take it for me and then like
telling everybody yeah that's like you
being having Down syndrome it's like you
just listen George it's like you having
Down syndrome right but you want a
degree at Harvard okay no you shouldn't
have it if you have the means get it to
pay but get somebody to like get
cosmetic surgery to look like you have
your ID
get a [ __ ] diploma and then now you
have a diploma College 101 with the body
[Music]